hello everyone I hope you're enjoying
your Sunday since we have a really wild
game between Magnus Carlsen Alexander
greet you from round three of the 2020
chess table masters and as I'm sure
you're going to enjoy it let's just
check it out and just a short
announcement I've enabled memberships on
the channel so if you guys are
interested in that I've explained it
everything in the first link in the
description below so do check that out
if such a thing interests you now
getting back to the game
Magnus with the white pieces opens with
d4 sorry bout that
and Grisha replies with Knight to f6
so Knight to f6 with c4 and east six and
Magnus goes Knight to c3 inviting Grisha
to go for the nimzo-indian defense which
Grichuk does so Bishop to b4 and we have
Knight to f3 here a lot of moves are
very popular Queen to c2 is popular III
is popular Bishop b2 Knight of three
that's not a knight of three but knight
of three is the line that Grisha goes
first the so-called three Knights of the
names oh and sorry Magnus goes for
ninety or three and Grisha castles here
and the Bishop to g5 by Magnus spinning
that night and now c5 so this is all
very standard we have III and see
characters on b4 we have characters and
now finally d5 we have C captors and e5e
capture son d5 and now Bishop to e2
Magnus prepares the castle and now h6
challenging this bishop asking do you
want to go back but if you go back then
maybe I will have some nights the e4
ideas so Magnus just captures it and
this is the most played move in the
position so Queen captures on f6 from
ratio and now Magnus just castles and
now bishop characters on c3 again the
most common move here we have B captures
and now Knight to c6 so asking black
asking white what do you wanna do here
and there is a well there are two very
interesting games you're actually both
in which my shocker mama dear I've had
the white pieces and rook to e1 was
played in Mahmud era both had this
position against Magnus Carlsen that
game he lost with rook to e1 but he also
had one game against Nakamura where he
won with rooked
one but here however Magnus goes for
night the b2 and it is now a new move in
the position Magnus is planning at the
go rook to e1 bring the knight over to
f1 and then shift the night over to e3
or g3 depending on what Grisha plays so
already as a move thirteen we have a
completely new game
so here a girlie show continues with
Bishop to e6 C continuous development
and rook to e1 continuing with his plan
of night to f1 here we have rook F the
c8 as the knight moves you wanna go
after the c3 pawn which is a weak pawn
probably the weakest weakest thing in
the karlsen's position and you want to
block hit it with let's say Knight to c4
and then maybe later on attack it so
night to f1 Magnus continues with his
plan and mount Knight to a5 opening up
an attack towards the pawn and preparing
Knight to c4 as you are expecting that
Carson will defend it which he does he
goes rook to c1 and now of course Knight
to c4 and now Queen to b3 are putting
pressure on the b7 pawn so Grisha
defends it we have b6 and now Magnus
decides to eliminate the c4 Knight as it
is quite the monster
so Bishop captures in c4 and now well
you could capture with the D pawn then
Queen just moves lets it to a 3 or b5 or
somewhere and then you already have
created a nice past D pawn so instead
the grigio factors that with the rook
now already preparing some look at the
c8 ideas with with just more pressure on
the c3 pawn so here at night the e3 now
Carson gets rid of the rook we have
looked the c6 in now Queen to a3 putting
pressure on the h7 pawn so you do not
allow the doubling of rooks and the C
file as then you just lose the a7 pawn
so here good issue goes for Queen to d8
first also Magnus could be planning some
like c4 characters and d5 just winning
material here so Grisha brings the Queen
back just to keep an eye on the d5
square however this is exactly what
Crossing goes for and it's also very
important since you really want to get
rid of this backwards c3 pawn it's the
biggest weakness in the position and it
does make sense to get rid of it so
Carlsen pushes c4 and it's a well it's
sort of a temporary to
pawn sacrifice that could either go well
or maybe not well we'll just have to see
what happens so but issue accepts it we
have d5 now of course threatening to win
material and the bishop captures on d5
so why did cross and sacrifice do pawns
well for rook C to D one and now there's
a double attack on the bishop here so we
should be defends it with rook to c5 and
now the problem is you would like the
double rooks here on the D file to add
another attacker here to the bishop on
d5 however if you go something like
rugby for Dan Queen e8 is very strong
and you will not be able to capture a
piece because the rook would be hanging
on e1 so here instead after this work to
c5 cross and first place rook to Queen
to c3 adds more protection to the rook
here and now rook to d4 is definitely an
idea
so Queen to d7 by Gary shook now
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game and now rook the d4 by Magnus
and here well you could go rook to b8
defending grisha plays the well more
aesthetically pleasing rook to e8 since
now again you do not have captures here
since after this black can just trade
everything Gogh captures captures
captures with check and after Queen
captures Queen also captures and well
black is just up two points in a
completely winning position there's the
the past C pawn there's not much white
can do about this
so after rook e8 we have rook eat the d1
now with a triple attack here against
Greece bishop but now Grisha well the
only way to avoid losing a piece here is
to give up the exchange which is what
the Grisha does and he's very happy to
do so as he is up up two pawns
so he doesn't mind so rook captures on
e3 we have Queen captures on e3 and now
leadership starts pushing this passed
pawn so C 3 and here again it's very
tricky for example if you try Queen to
d3 right away to win material here then
c2 is very strong and after Luke the c1
then you can just move the Queen let's
say with Queen to be 504 Oh Queen trade
and it would be a very very difficult
position for a white to play let's say
if you capture here you can just capture
back rook characters here and then you
could win back your pawn giving back the
exchange however it's still very
unpleasant white black is still up upon
and it's due two against one on the
Queen
side black would have very good chances
here so instead after this c3 pushed
Magnus goes f3 doesn't allow any any
tricks here against the g2 pawn and now
Queen to c6 I just adding more pressure
to the c2 pond so now you can push it by
both defending it with the Queen and the
ship and now comes Queen to d3 again now
putting pressure on the bishop so now C
to Magnus attacks the rook we have
worked the c1 and now rook the c3
challenging the crossings Queen on d3 so
he has to move it while maintaining the
pressure on the bishop here the threat
is still just Queen captures and now
Gary shook well the point is if you just
move the bishop you're getting
checkmated check Queen covers h7 you
have to block and it's checkmate so here
instead
after this Queen to f8 my Magna Graecia
found the only move that allows black to
keep the advantage which of course you
are more than eager to find while
pausing the video while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on unpinning with a threat and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
its Queen to EA Queen to e8 you try and
give up the bishop of course for this
very very dangerous Queen to e3 check
and here white is completely lost after
you move it you pick up the rook with
check then you bring the Queen back with
check then the King has to go somewhere
of course you don't want to go to f1 so
you go to g3 and then black just brings
another Queen into the game and after y
delivers one check there are no more
checks and black has two queens so of
course completely winning so after this
Queen that eh move by Grisha Magnus went
Queen to f4 defense the the rook here on
c1 also adds more protection to the e3
squared but now Bishop character Sunday
- and all of a sudden Grisha has whoa
Grisha has three passed pawns here on
the Queen side and this is now just
complete the domination by black so here
Magnus goes Queen to d2 he wants the
trap Gary sucks Queen by playing rook to
b8 but the grecian just moves the Queen
and he says I'm not worried about any
checks here after making
reaches the h7 square sorry about that
there are no more useful check so I'm
not really worried about this
so Magnus goes rook the a4 instead he
says okay you either capture my rook and
then I'm gonna get rid of this rook
while also capturing the c2 pawn or if
you move the bishop then I can gobble up
the a7 pawn at least reduce some
pressure on the Queen side so here we
have Queen the c5 check by Gary shook
King the h1 and now just Bishop back to
e6 leadership says okay have at it
you're welcome to grab the a7 pawn I'm
just gonna do my thing
so here Carson does it with real
characters on a 7 and now Grisha just
plays b5 and now if if he's allowed to
play B 4 B 3 and B 2 it's just game over
so Carlson has to play something really
really really quick so it looked at a 5
stopping b4 for the moment and now rook
the c4 keeping an eye on the B 4 square
while preparing Queen to c6 and B 4 so
here we have h3 by Magnus create some
breathing room for the king and now
Queen to c6 by Gary shook a very very
dangerous idea we have Queen to d8 check
King to h7 and now Queen to d3 check but
now grief is more than happy to play g6
it's not a problem
it is our weakening in the position
however black doesn't have a dark square
bishop to take advantage of this and the
light square bishop well is just keeping
everything nicely defended the rooks are
helpless against this f7 pawn bishop
barrier and here we have Queen to d8 by
Magnus here Magnus is planning rook to
e8 and he wants to deliver checkmate
however there is there is a move here
and this move is so beautiful that I'm
sure you see it right away so feel free
to pause the video and try to find it
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations I'm sure you've spotted
it right away and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's a bunch
of captures on h3 and here white just
resigns there is no defense against this
of course if the bishop is captured then
just Queen captures on f3 with check and
after let's say King moves anywhere then
Queen if you check into h1 and now rook
the c3 with the threat of checkmate and
there's not much you can do about this
Queen d7 can the
but Nauru g3 and there is no defense
against this checkmate whatever you play
it's just mate
so what could happen here is that after
you capture on h3 is that white doesn't
capture which doesn't make sense like he
plays king h2 attacks the bishop but now
you just bring the bishop back and now
well without the h3 pawn it's just a
completely lost position there is no
rook to e8 anymore since the bishop cut
off the rooks d8 square is nicely
covered the rook is also ready to jump
to h4 if the Queen ever moves you can
just start pushing the beep on to
victory
so everything is winning here for black
however Grisha played b4 instead he
wants to start pushing the pawn right
away and this is still perfectly fine
but it allows Magnus this unnecessary
counter play would work the a8 however
we have Bishop the c8 degree shook now
blocks the Queen's access to the h8
square which would deliver checkmate and
now cross and goes for rook the b8 again
stops the b3 the de beep on for moving
to b3 but also has a very dangerous
threat and here we should consider
something like Queen C fiber just Queen
d7 trading Queens which would be
extremely strong here however grecian
goes King to g7 and now he gives Magnus
this one move that allows him to go back
into the game so once again feel free to
pause the video here for the last time
and find the best defensive move for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations are not
just being a great attacker but also on
being a great defender that's also super
important and for those who just wanna
enjoy the show it's rook to b6 and now
there's a problem the Queen is under
attack and there's not much you can do
well if you go Queen d7 if you try to
trade Queens now the problem is going to
pass across and has Queen to f6 check
and after the King moves this rook to d6
is deadly with the threat of route d8
and the rook to h8 or queen - a
checkmate so here black would have to
offer a queen trade but now after Queen
B - you still keep an eye on the h8
square threatening this and now after
rook rook the c3 blocking now you can
just go rook the d2 and now you can pick
up this point you can pick up this
there's not much you can do here black
could try something like rook captures
an f3 again to create some sort of a
mating threat but white can just ignore
you with let's say characters in situ
and it's still not much better let's say
rook F 1 check characters and captures
with check King H 2 and now we could
even see a repetition with Queen f4
check or King G 1 and then let's say you
get this where yeah it'd still be
exchanged but black is up two points and
with with a pretty much untenable
position
so after this rook the b6 idea Grisha
played Queen to c7 he offered the Queen
trade and here Magnus gladly accepts
because now Queen characters and rook
captures he gets rook captures on b4 and
he eliminated a very important point
which if Grisha was able to do it would
just be game over and the reason Grisha
of course did not find such sneaky moves
the ended this game is because again he
was extremely low on time so here we
have g5 but g4 by magnets not allowing
Bishop to a5 to just cement to this pawn
and c2 so rook the c3 going after the f3
pawn but now King to g2 we have Bishop
to d7 preparing to guard the pawn with
Bishop day for if the rook attacks it
and after rook to be - not Bishop to a
for this time by Grisha but rather he
goes for a more active idea Bishop to c6
now puts pressure on the pawn here and
Magnus now just captures the sea to pawn
so rook be captures and c2 and now
Bishop captures on f3 with check King g3
and now you have to capture otherwise if
you move then the bishop will just get
get captured or if you move somewhere
let's say here then just rook the c3
again will force you to trade so grip
trades right away with characters
characters and now Bishop to d5 keeping
an eye on the pawn here and now work the
c5 Bishop to e6 and now h4 and it was in
this position unmoor 54 that the players
agreed to a draw as if there is no way
to push for a win here with white even
though you're up the exchange point is
that let's say you character captures
captures that there's not much you can
do here King to g6 and there's no way to
for white the
ever get across this barrier let's say
you you get rid of one of the pawns
captures captures with check and King g6
now you don't have you need at least one
point to be able to play positions like
this for a win for example at some point
you might outmaneuver the black King to
get away you could get your own King
somewhere around here and then maybe
sacrifice your rook for the bishop and
the pawn and if you had one more pawn
then maybe depending on the position it
would be winning however here you don't
have such luxury so of course after hh4
they agreed to a draw and what what a
wild game really beautifully played
nimzo-indian defense by Corey shook
cross and went for the ball double pawn
sacrifice but Gary shook said I'm just
gonna counter sacrifice with a nice
exchange sacrifice to keep my extra
points and then just push the past C
pawn and he almost did it but as usual
Gary shook his own worst enemy
you know just didn't have enough time to
finish this game so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Marco Cabral Ahana tomochka Alex
tan Alexander deal and Eric Holtmann for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think'll for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the chasuble chasuble
masters 20/20 checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day